um
you guys know him i'm sure you've seen
the videos all over facebook because it
gets pushed all the time is that adam
ruins everything guy
uh adam ruins everything is is basically
a lefty who sits there and he makes
these wacky videos on everything the
everything you believe is wrong and
again just to point out if you do watch
adam uh
ruins everything videos you find out
that his sources are always vox
the splc
slate
like he's very very writing so he was on
uh he was on rogan show
and they were talking about trans
children hormone debate so you know
[ __ ] giving hormones to kids as
athletes go you know we could have we
could sit here and talk for three hours
about like all the different ways that
hormones might affect your body might
not affect your body and i'm not an
expert on that i don't want to claim to
be right but
a sports with uh
trans athletes who are uh you know
competing with the you know with their
gender right that's uh that is a
sporting world that i'm more interested
in right and i think we should find a
way to make that happen i know it's
gonna be really complicated complicated
and messy right
um and uh there's gonna be a lot of
debate about it and it's gonna make it's
gonna be uncomfortable you know there's
gonna be a lot of arguments but you know
i hope that that's the world that we've
moved forward to that's my that's my
point of view he's such a [ __ ] by the
way something else you need to point out
about adam he's not a smart man he's not
no he has writers that put all the stuff
together for him people think that
hookah jesus you're so smart he knows
all he doesn't know anything okay
he's basically the best way to describe
him is he's one of these lefty new york
alt comedians yeah you know yeah and not
even really a comedian it was probably
like a funny blogger funny blogger yeah
there you go like a perez hilton type
my point of view is that there's a
reason there's a distinction
there's a reason why we make the
distinction to have male athletics
versus female athletics the reason is
that males have a physiological
physiological advantage over women so in
most sports most physical sports we do
not have males compete with females the
question becomes when someone who is
male transitions and becomes female
do those same physiological advantages
apply and what what are the what is the
evidence well the evidence and
competition seems to be that it shows
that it does apply particularly in
weightlifting
rugby
mountain biking power heavy sports that
are that favor larger people
stronger bodies males that transition to
females have a significant advantage in
their breaking world records so if
you're a woman and you're a natural
woman and you don't take any extra
hormones or male hormones you're not
taking steroids or any sort of
performance enhancing drugs you're doing
your very best to compete and you're at
the top of the heap but then someone
comes along that was a man for 30 years
and decides that they're going to be a
woman and this has happened and
literally transitioned a few months ago
and competes as a woman and destroys
records and dominates you yeah it's been
happening more and more we've talked
used to be outliers even when the show
first started but there was a track that
track team the a high school track team
where there was just two black dudes
turned into girls all of a sudden and
they were destroying everybody the power
lift the guy who broke all the
powerlifting records was just a dude
breaking powerlifting records and there
was that the mma fighter fox yeah fallon
fox
broke the the orbital ball brutal it was
brutal
no you're not allowed you're not allowed
you're not allowed
logically a male and who is a male for
30 plus years of having testosterone run
through their body and affect their
tendon strength and affect the shape of
their bones and the mechanical
advantages of the male hips versus the
female hips and then they're competing
with smaller
people who have been a woman their whole
life it's not fair it's it's is as much
cheating as taking steroids when the
other person doesn't or taking
performance-enhancing drugs when the
other person doesn't maybe even more
yeah cause guess what a lot of them are
on there are on roids they are they're
turning them
and you think they're not gonna overdo
it yeah
if you're a female becoming a man you're
taking testosterone maybe even more so
because you also have
there's a bunch of advantages in terms
of reaction time that males enjoy it's
like it's some significant difference in
reaction time between males and even
untrained males versus female
professional athletes well i i disagree
and and what do you disagree about
i love i love this is the perfect
example of a leftist yeah well i
disagree you well what do you do what
though i just
i
yeah
what's your argument yeah i disagree and
then notice no
there's
my argument is no
there's there's a running theme with
this little interview the interview is
him saying well i'm not an expert well
i'm not a he says that a lot watch i've
already well the my main point being the
one that i already made right that like
i don't think that there is such a thing
as a perfectly level playing field i
think we decide what kind of playing
field we want to have sure but we do
make the distinction where we don't
allow men to compete in women's
divisions and i think that that
distinction may be breaking down a bit
right and i think it may be time to
break down that distinction a little bit
so you think that males
let me point something out i just want i
want to point something out
a guy you know who else hates this
feminist yes adam adam a guy who's never
played
a sport
a day in his life
who's never played any a sport or done
any athletic activity and never look
like a guy who even played like
casually
i played football in college one year i
played baseball when i was in middle
school and stuff this guy's never
ever played a sport yeah i played little
league yeah [ __ ] jv football one year
like it wasn't good but that wasn't good
either that's why but you still learn a
[ __ ] lesson from an experience and
you can you can kind of go wow yeah i've
been hit hard and i know that
his argue joe wrote look man again we
always criticize but in this particular
this argument we have to be fair joe
rogan's bringing up no here's actually
what happens here's what happens when
you take this when you take that and it
affects this it affects that i don't
agree i'm just gonna say well i disagree
well that's not how it works adam and i
think it should be different
right and i think it may be time to
break down that distinction so you think
that male should be able to compete in
the women's division of weightlifting uh
no i don't necessarily um but they can
if they transition uh well
first of all uh uh
he's
he's that's it windows xp shotgun we all
agree yeah rogan's not exactly [ __ ]
ben shapiro no but compared to this guy
what i'm saying is like if joe rogan is
frying your [ __ ] sensors yeah he's
crushing you i'm not uh you're not mr
super duper it's not like you could
either easily have had uh jordan
peterson there uh you could have ben
shapiro there but no you have joe rogan
completely shorting your system out neon
fire squad says his mom got dodgeball
cancelled that's that's exactly who adam
is not my son no
but yeah and you notice a joke too like
joe isn't even like
getting riled up no or anything
oh man it's just that's that's terrible
well i'm not good
what i'm
he's losing it
joe rogan right now is being the cop
that comes in with just a cup of coffee
and it's just like
oh man so tell me about it what happened
it's the light i'm like all right look
man the [ __ ] she just kept nagging me
and nagging me and nagging me like just
started stabbing and i started staring
and joe's like all right cool man you
didn't even sip your coffee or anything
but you're under arrest you know what
this is a good point when it comes rogan
might not be the smartest guy with
everything but aj's got a point joe
knows about this he cares about it
because of mma and that's a good point
like this is something that he actually
does know this is true it's a great it's
one of his
go-to debates that he's done many times
yeah but even that it's like he's still
not like he's not going that hard on him
yeah he's just going like well you know
i'm just saying like reaction times
their hips are built differently well
dude that's just i should stoop did i
disagree
that's not an answer
and joe's just you can tell he's he's a
little extra high in this one yeah he's
just like man what are you talking about
it's crazy don't do that
the
there's there's a lot of stuff to break
down right and i'm not an expert on the
subject right so it's just sort of my
off the top of my head um one thing is
you know you're postulating uh a
particular person who decided to
transition uh at the age of 30 right and
they were very big and strong before
right and they decided no no no no no
he's not postulating it
that has happened
the body built the body the power lifter
so far the only trans athletes have been
ones that are like oh i could cheat so
easily yeah [ __ ] what is what are you
talking about
the transition now that is a type of
person that exists right
um i think over the next certainly 30
years we're gonna see you know uh now
that uh people are starting to
understand that being trans is just a
way that people are right they're just
people who are trans you know and this
is something that we're gonna hey
hey adam hey adam i have something to
tell you buddy um
if you think
if you think we're gonna
spend the next 30 years giving less than
three percent of the population this
much ground to keep [ __ ] our systems
and our institutions up i think you got
another thing coming pal because
everything's cyclical and i have a very
big feeling that this is all going to
get shut down at some point adam is
somebody and everybody knows somebody
like this who thinks the entire country
is brooklyn
because he's indeed these people are
living these echo chambers they live in
these if you live in brooklyn
you're in chelsea you're living in these
places all you're hearing all the time
is you're right trans athletes and yeah
i don't know why i said three percent
sorry
but yeah it's less than half percent but
it's like you think we're gonna you
think we're gonna keep shutting down
every goddamn town hall meeting and
every [ __ ] every meeting of the uh
athletic commission in every state of
the world every day for the next 30
years over these people
i think you have another thing coming i
think something's going to come to a
head and people are going to go look we
don't give a [ __ ] be trans put enough of
this nonsense yeah stop enough
support right you're seeing folks
transition much much earlier age you
know um uh
but then and and so if someone is if
let me see let me tell you something
you almost never interrupt you you you
no no but look at joe's face you never
see joe do this face i've never seen him
be this watch you could this is joe what
is at his most upset much earlier age
you know um
but then and and so if someone is did
you see them
he that's joe hiding
and again we [ __ ] criticized joe a
lot but that's joe hiding disgust did
you see him he was holding the
disgusting because if someone is you
know transitioning from the age of like
you know i think there's a bit of
empathy too i think he's just feeling
empathy this guy's a stupid man cause
like i when i think of that too i'm like
oh those [ __ ] kids man like you're
doing this people like you were doing it
adam right um and uh you know working
with those hormones you know uh from
that age right they're not gonna have
you know that their body situation would
be very different than the one that you
that you postulated right you know adam
reminds me of and even looks like and
this is just for you and maybe with two
people listening nathan
uh i also oh and by the way you
shouldn't be using postulated like more
than once in a conversation because then
you sound like a guy with a limited
vocabulary
that's correct
from my trans friends that the uh
transfects that the hormones have on
your body are like really profound you
know like really really profound like
we're not like um
to a surprising degree right
uh and so uh
you know i have look
if the question is how does
you know how does a person who starts
taking hormones at a particular age
right how does their body change and how
does that affect vis-a-vis athletic
performance i i don't know we're in such
new territory here right we certainly
are and we particularly we just
scratched upon the idea of kids
transitioning at a very early age i mean
there's been more scientific evidence
and points that if kids don't do that
than when they wanted to be trans at an
early age they just become gay men and
that there's nothing wrong with that
either
there's no reason to give kids hormones
and there's no reason to decide before a
person's frontal lobe is completely
completely fully developed which doesn't
even take place until like 25.
people don't know who they are yes a
seven-year-old
you you won't even people don't even
give their seven-year-old phones you
don't let them vote you're going to let
them decide what sex they're going to do
for the rest of their life the research
that i've seen and again i'm not an
expert on this and and
this this is a theme here's the thing i
wish someone would cut up the i'm not an
expert how many times
for a guy who's not an expert you sure
like to sound like one and you sure like
to tell everybody how it needs to go you
have a show
telling people why they're wrong
and you know i'd love to
this is a conversation this is something
i'd love to talk about on our show and
i'd specifically love you know this is
before this is the kind of topic where i
really want to
make sure that i know the research and
that i'm you know also speaking to trans
folks you know um in in this
conversation but so to touch on just
what i've you know my own experience and
what i've well okay are you gonna speak
to people that have trans regret are you
just gonna speak to the ones see that's
the thing they stay they they built
these [ __ ] they built these straw man
arguments out of like well my trans
friends okay but are you gonna talk to
the people that regret it because
there's a lot of people that regret it
but no they only they only talk to a
boost their
the research i've seen the research i've
seen is that trans kids from a young age
uh they are incredibly consistent in
their when you know when they're
expressing their gender identity uh what
research is big generalization
talking about a lot of human beings
yeah yeah but the that's that's fits
this narrative by saying they're
incredibly consistent but like if you
polled these people like what are you
talking about like if you i mean that's
uh i look i i don't have a research in
front of me that i saw you don't have
you know why you don't have the research
in front of you
because there's literally no research a
vox article isn't research
something on pink news
isn't research adam
i've always hated this guy i've hated
disguise
i've always hated him
so i can't like go into the details on
it but like yeah it was i mean it was
you know it was uh research that was
surveying and tracking like trans kids
who declared their identity from a young
age did it change the answer was uh
generally no it really didn't um and uh
you know i have a friend who has a who
has a trans kid um don't know the kid's
exact age but you know we're in the age
range that we're talking about
and you you have a friend with a trans
kid in the age range you're talking
about you and your friend should be
removed from society and the child
should luckily hopefully young enough be
put in a good home
because this just because everything is
i have a friend the left sources these
[ __ ] loony people sources is always
their friends or their buddies or a
cousin or the or the or when the
abortion debate the girl that got raped
it's always that it's always that this
is uh
this guy's just
raw propaganda that's all it is yeah of
course
you know he's explained that like well
you know my child from a very young age
consistently like said i am a girl like
and has never contradicted themselves
never changed their mind and so the
humane thing they have said consistently
that they are a girl because these
lefties don't understand cause and
effect
their parents have probably been nailing
into them since they were [ __ ] since
they could talk
even before they could talk you don't
have to be a boy or a girl you can pick
you can pick so the kid thinks it's a
game and they'll pick girl and they
stick with girl shut the [ __ ] up
and the thing that he felt was gonna do
as a parent was to like embrace that
choice on his child's part right um and
yeah that's embrace that choice meaning
hormonally i shouldn't even phrase it as
a choice like like embrace that identity
um but it is a choice right i mean if
you're choosing to add hormones to a
child's body that's a choice uh it's a
it's a choice
on the part of the parent um it's not a
choice in the
on the uh on the part of the child okay
so what you're saying is is that
the parent has a choice to give hormones
but the kid has no choice this doesn't
make any sense their whole argument
falls apart it's so wonky these people
have have sjw themselves into such a
corner that they don't know how to get
out of it
to like in the same way that being let's
say that being gay isn't a choice yeah
okay but if that's who they are if they
think that they're a girl
why do you have to give them hormones to
make them more of a girl
uh
that's a goddamn good question
well i'm not an expert
he might as well throw a [ __ ] smoke
bomb down and just run yeah at this
point he's he's never gonna go back on
the show again i guarantee you they made
him joe made him look like a fool
it's a simple question if you say that
the child thinks it's a girl so you're
going to give the child hormones
if the child thinks it's a girl let it
be a girl like you don't have why are
you adding hormones if you're shooting
hormones into a child
and you're affecting the child's
development you're saying that's not a
choice that's nonsense of course it's a
choice you're choosing to chemically
change this child's body you're choosing
to inject things into this child's body
on a regular basis that are going to
radically affect the physical
development of their body yeah and
you're saying that this isn't a choice
well it's definitely a choice to do that
so so kkk says transgender athletes are
great once again men have proven they
are better than uh at women and
everything
uh so they even make better women yes
thank you what trans people express um
and again i'm not an expert this is from
me talking to my trans friends and and
you know uh seeing what other trans
folks say
i hate this man everything but i'm so
you know what i hate this man i hate
this man i hate this man i hate this man
i am so glad that this happened though
because so many people have been loving
this guy and saying how great he is and
how awesome he is and he's always just
breaking stuff down man he just deals in
facts and you realize he has no facts
he's not a smart man he's a dumb man i
have no research what reason what's his
schooling does he have a degree in
anything you see my trans friends yeah
but that's not having a degree having
somebody who mutilated their genitals is
not allowed to be a reference point in a
research paper you can't do that it's
never been a research paper that started
with and dr smith has a friend who
mutilated his genitals so that'll be
that'll be the control source that's not
how it works